what is a zero based budget
well let's define a budget first your
average budget is a monthly estimate of
income and expenses with a list of
categories in other words it's just a
plan for your money
and Ramsey solutions we recommend taking
it one step further with a zero based
budget the idea here is simple the money
that comes in minus the money that goes
out equals zero meaning you've told
every penny exactly where it's gonna go
just like how you told that guy in
traffic exactly where he was gonna go
now making a zero based budget isn't as
hard as it sounds
step one list your take-home pay for the
month step two lists all your expenses
for the month but start with these five
categories
food shelter utilities transportation
and clothing the basics you want to make
sure your rent or mortgage is budgeted
at first before you start budgeting for
something like your hot yoga membership
Jeff once the necessities are taken care
of move to step three list the rest of
your expenses like haircuts Netflix date
nights plus all the stuff your kids need
our kids really that expensive don't let
life catch you off guard think ahead and
plan for events or situations you need
to save up for holidays weddings
birthdays bar mitzvahs quinceaneras
chupacabras you name it you can even
create a fund in your budget to put
aside money every month so you're ready
when that day comes Christmas is on
December 25th again don't act surprised
people now if you work through every
expense for the month and you still have
a hundred bucks left you haven't
finished your budget quite yet
you've got to get Uncle Ben a job put it
towards your debt for example or maybe
buy something that can help you figure
this money stuff out I can't think of
anything off the top of my head that
could do that
but I can't do a budget cuz I'm bad at
math well lucky for you there's an app
for everything there's like five of them
just for finding the nearest bathroom
that's not a joke look it up get on your
smartphone and download our free
budgeting tool every dollar because no
matter your in-game pain your way
through college getting out of debt
buying your first home or even planning
for retirement your budget is the key to
keeping it 100 and now you know
[Music]